hi guys i'm matt and welcome to tasty's
hack or hassle
on this show tasty producers attempt to
make their favorite dishes using a bunch
of hacks as collected by our friend
annie i
love burgers so i'm very curious to see
how these hacks are going to
change the overall outcome and the
flavor of our burgers
this is your classic american
cheeseburger to me it is the perfect
food
super simple but always extremely
satisfying but you know what i'm curious
to see
how our hacks will reshape how i make
burgers
let's get started on making our patty
now the first hack annie gave me
is to use multiple types of meat in your
burger rather than just one
i'm using a blend of sirloin chuck and
short rib
and this is just gonna add a lot of nice
flavor it's gonna allow me to sort of
dial in
exactly what i wanna taste if i want it
more beefy if i want it more fatty
whatever blend you want you can dial it
into however you want it to taste
the next hack is to actually add baking
soda
to the meat mixture this is supposed to
help it brown it's supposed to kind of
kick start that my yard reaction
i don't usually have an issue with my
burgers browning so i'm curious to see
if this
makes them brown on steroids or if it's
just going to look kind of the same
and it's really important with burgers
to not over mix
you don't want to break down all the fat
you don't want to make them too dense
either
this next hack is wetting your hands
with cold water to prevent the patties
from sticking so you can
shape the ultimate patty as long as
you're not working with the beef for too
long it shouldn't really stick to your
hands i think it starts to stick when it
kind of melts and warms up
i think this is easy to get around but
we'll see so this looks nice to me i
don't want to work with it too much i
don't want to overwork my beef but i
have to say there's like nothing stuck
to my hands right now
look at that before i set this down
there's one more little hack that i want
to try so it's basically the thumb
technique
i'm just going to take my thumb and make
a little divot in the middle and the
idea is that when the burger is cooking
it's going to start to get like tight
it's going to start to form a ball
almost
this is going to help it remain nice and
flat and keep its shape a lot more this
next hack actually involves the lid of a
jar of peanut butter
so the idea is that you can use the lid
to help shape
your patties what i am going to thumbs
down is using the peanut butter jar lid
itself kind of small this would work
really really well
if say i was making a slider but for a
burger it's a little bit petite
so i'm actually going to set this aside
and i'm going to introduce my own hack
so this is something i learned at a
restaurant i was working at years and
years ago these are deli containers
you'll get them a lot with
takeout so the idea is that i'm going to
use these two containers to shape my
patty
i'm just going to press it in there a
little bit i don't want to like force it
in
too much and then i'm just going to take
the second lid press it down
gently i don't want to like squish my
beef too much
and there you go going to make a little
divot in the top so my burger kind of
bows out
and here are the two patties i really
really like the deli container one it
looks very uniform the edge is super
exact
the hand shaped one also looks great it
looks very
thick so i think both of these are going
to turn out pretty okay and i'm excited
to see how they cook up the next hack is
to actually pop these patties in the
fridge or freezer for about 20 to 30
minutes just to kind of cool them i
think the idea is that the cold is gonna
help them
hold their shape a lot more while
they're cooking if they're too warm and
if they're too like melted they're just
gonna fall apart but i'm very curious to
see what the results are going to be
my burger patties have been chilling in
the fridge for about 20 to 30 minutes
chilling it in the fridge has made it
nice and firm it's holding its shape
together really really nicely
it is time to start cooking our patties
i have a
cast iron pan here just heating up you
can use nonstick you can use whatever
pans you have you can use a grill
but i'm going with cast iron i love cast
iron it retains heat really well
this next hack involves adding mustard
to our patties a lot of places actually
do grilled mustard on their burgers just
to add a little bit more flavor to
zhu [ __ ] a little bit she's sizzling i
can really smell the mustard it's like
in the air it smells so
good i'm very skeptical of this hack the
idea is that you take chips of ice and
you place them in the little divots you
made on the top of the burger
i feel like if you don't overcook them
they'll stay moist regardless of whether
or not there's ice
but let's see what happens the burgers
have already been in the pan for a few
minutes
i don't know if having the cold burger
patty with the cold
ice it doesn't seem to really be working
it's not melting all that quickly
and now it is time to flip my burgers i
don't know if i love the way the mustard
looks actually maybe i applied it too
thick maybe it's supposed to be a super
thin layer
this next hack don't press your burgers
don't flip them around too much don't
play with them
i think that's pretty much a best
practice when you're cooking in general
you want that mayard reaction to really
do its magic
and to make things nice and crispy and
caramelized one of the ways i like to
gauge the dentist of my burgers
is i check on the sides to see how far
up the pink extends
if i'm noticing it's starting to cook
through nicely and there's not as much
pink visible
i can usually assume that it's like the
right doneness on the inside
and so that's kind of my metric for how
i know when my burgers are done
the next and sort of final cooking hack
is putting the cheese on while it's
still in the pan so the residual heat
from the pan helps it melt faster
rather than throwing it on at the end
and hoping it melts all the way on top
i prefer american i know some people are
sticklers oh it's technically not real
cheese
it melts like nothing else but you can
use any cheese that you want and there
we have it
the cheese has melted nicely over the
top it's kind of
enrobed my burger a bit at this stage in
the game i can see
a couple of my hacks and how they've had
an impact on everything
they've retained their nice flat burger
profile and i think a lot of that is due
to that little divot that we put in the
inside so it didn't sort of curl up on
itself
so again another great hack that's
worked really really well for these
burgers earlier we added baking soda to
help the browning of the burgers so i
just want to take a look at the bottom
here
oh wow it looks like the baking soda
worked but how much
more did it work we'll check in on that
later these burgers apparently need to
rest for about 10 minutes just to let
the juices redistribute i think this is
gonna work because the best practice
with all meat is to let it rest for a
few minutes afterwards
and so these babies are just gonna chill
for a bit and then we'll check them out
now the bun is the most underrated and
one of the most important parts of a
burger so we have to get this right
i have in front of me a pretzel bun you
can use whatever bun you want for this
what's important is that you have a
whole bun so we are going to
take our bun and just slice through it
and before we go
all the way through we're going to stop
so basically we have a little hinge
on the end here and this is to a hold
our bun together
it's also going to create an edge where
not all of our toppings are going to
spill out at least i think that's the
point of it
shake shack does this on their burgers
so i'm very curious to see how it works
here
now every great burger has a toasted bun
to me
that's a fact we're going to be trying
to cook our buns
in the leftover fat and juices that are
in the pan
i'm just going to take a little paper
towel here and just use it to dab up
a lot of that excess fat it's nice and
heated up i'm just going to take my bun
plop her in there and before i finish i
just want to turn it around i want to
make sure that i get
every little bit coated with that beef
fat and i'm just going to let this sit
you can even see it sizzling just along
the outside there
all right in time for the grand reveal i
don't know about you that looks pretty
nice to me
cooking in your leftover beef fat i
think works beautifully
you don't have to obviously you can
toast your buns in butter
oil whatever you want but we want to use
everything and now that my bun
is toasted and my patties are seared
it's time to assemble a burger and now
it is time for our final hack
and that is how to properly assemble a
burger now this particular hack involves
putting our condiments on the bottom
your bottom bun is less likely to get
soggy
and the idea is that the mayo is super
super fatty and so what that's going to
do is that's going to create almost like
a waterproof little layer on the bottom
and i'm just going to repeat with my
ketchup and now i'm just going to take
my lettuce
this lettuce creates a waterproof
barrier so that our burger juices don't
get down into the patty two nice slices
of tomato
and now finally star of our show our
burger patty
there we go my top bun is now completely
separated from the bottom bun
i think that really has to do with just
the thickness of the burger if you were
making a thin smash burger this would
work a lot better
but because my burger's so thick doesn't
really work so i'm not going to suggest
it for this particular style
i for one am happy with how this looks
but the real test is going to come when
we compare it to our control
burger
and here it is my hack burger comparing
them to each other
they certainly look different i think
the most noticeable
and most visual difference i can see is
my packed burger
is way darker and way browner than my
regular burger which i think is due to
the baking soda that we put in before
very surprising i didn't expect it to be
that different we gotta start with the
regular one
it's a good burger it's nice it's
flavorful i'm a little thrown by the
untoasted bun
i don't know if that's a thing on a lot
of burgers or just in this case
but like the lack of a crunch is really
really standing out to me all right my
friend
let's see how you did
this tastes very different the patty on
this there's something about it that
feels like
a little bit like chewier almost and a
little bit denser
but it's so much darker everywhere than
this burger whereas like the simplicity
of the unhacked burger i almost wonder
if the addition of the baking soda made
it like
too dark and made it change super
radically i do think that the burger
with my toppings underneath has stayed
together a lot better
i think when they're on top here it kind
of starts to run awry
at the end of the day i think putting
toppings on the bottom
is kind of the way to go i think it's a
nice work around my grilled mustard i
can
taste it but it's very very subtle it's
kind of like in the background i only
notice it when i'm really really looking
for it i think if it was a thinner
burger patty the musser would read a lot
better but because it's so thick it's
just kind of overshadowed by everything
gonna have to go meth on it i think it
really just depends on the type of
burger that you're making
the hacked burger definitely has a nice
beefy flavor to it i think a lot of that
came from the combination of meats that
we used in the beginning
but there's so much going on in this
burger that it kind of gets lost and i
think at the end of the day
simpler just kind of wins so i used a
lot of hacks to make this burger
which ones were my favorite one wetting
my hands to prevent the ground beef from
sticking
worked really really well i was very
impressed with that two
making the divot for the thumb in the
top so that the burgers kept their
shapes while they were cooking
and three adding the toppings to the
bottom i definitely think
helped the burger stay together better
and just made it more structurally
stable
let me know what burger hacks you know
of in the comments below
and until next time take care my friends
[Music]
[Music]